CAN DO ♪
♪.
STEVE: GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME
TO THE NEXT REVOLUTION.
I'M STEVE HILTON AND THIS IS THE
HOME OF POSITIVE POPULISM.
I JUST WANT TO SAY ONE THING AT
THE BEGINNING.
I WANT TO SAY A HUGE THANK YOU
TO ALL OF YOU WHO GOT BEHIND OUR
JOE CHINA CAMPAIGN LAST WEEK ON
SWAMP WATCH.
THAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT AND WE
GOT ONE THAT COMING UP LATER
TONIGHT BUT I WANT TO SAY THANKS
TO ALL OF YOU WHO GOT THAT
GOING.
I WANT TO START THE SHOW WITH
THIS.
>> SARAH SANDERS ASKING
REPORTERS TO TURN THE PAGE AS IT
RELATES TO THE MUELLER REPORT.
I HAVE TO REMIND YOU DON'T TURN
THE PAGE, TURN BACK.
LOOK AT THE PAGE BUT WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS NEED TO DO TO KEEP THE
FOCUS ON THE MUELLER REPORT?
STEVE: THAT IS IT.
WHAT DO THEY NEED TO DO TO KEEP
THE FOCUS ON RUSSIA?
THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE ECONOMY BECAUSE IT IS
BOOMING AND DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT POLICIES BECAUSE THEY ARE
INCREASINGLY LOONY.
THEY JUST WANT TO TALK ABOUT
RUSSIA AND DIVIDE AMERICA IN THE
PROCESS.
REMEMBER THAT AS YOU HEAR THEM
AND LESLIE PONTIFICATING ABOUT
THAT TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
IT IS ALL JUST A POLITICAL
TACTIC TO KEEP THE FOCUS ON
RUSSIA.
TONIGHT I WANT TO PROVE THAT TO
YOU FORENSICALLY, IN DETAIL,
WITH FACTS AND THEIR OWN WORDS
AND WATCH CLOSELY.
STEVE: LET'S LOOK AT THE
ARGUMENT THE ESTABLISHMENT USES
AS A JUSTIFICATION FOR ALL THIS
WITH THE NATIONAL SECURITY
REQUIREMENTS TO STAND UP TO
RUSSIA IN ITS BEHAVIOR.
HERE'S AN OLD FRIEND TALKING
ABOUT JUST THAT LAST WEEK.
>> YOU ARE IN THE KREMLIN AND
YOU ARE VLADIMIR PUTIN WHO I
HAVE SAT ACROSS AND UNDERSTAND
HIS GOAL IS TO BEGIN AMERICA.
I KNOW THAT.
HE DOES NOT LIKE ME BECAUSE I'VE
STOOD UP FOR AMERICA.
STEVE: ARE YOU THINKING WHAT I'M
THINKING?
PLAY THE TAPE
>> I WANTED TO PRESENT YOU WITH
A LITTLE GIFT WHICH REPRESENTS
WHAT PRESIDENT OBAMA AND VICE
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND I HAVE BEEN
SAYING AND THAT IS WE WANT TO
RESET OUR RELATIONSHIP.
STEVE: ACTUALLY WE FOUND A
BETTER ONE AND THIS IS SOMETHING
SHE SAID ON RUSSIAN TV.
PERHAPS SHE HOPED WE WOULD NOT
FIND IT BUT WE DID QUOTE -- WE
WANT VERY MUCH TO HAVE A STRONG
RUSSIA BECAUSE OF STRONG
COMPETENT, PROSPEROUS AND STABLE
RUSSIA IS IN THE INTEREST OF THE
WORLD.
STICK IT TO PUTIN, HILLARY.
OF COURSE, IT WAS NOT JUST HER
BUT HERE IS PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
WHY HE WAS ON RUSSIA AND
UKRAINE.
FACT --
THE ESTABLISHMENT FROTHING AT
THE MOUTH OVER HIM NOT RAISING
MEDDLING WITH PUTIN ON THEIR
CALL THIS FRIDAY.
HANG ON A SECOND.
DID NOT THE MEDDLING HAPPEN
UNDER OBAMA WHO WAS TOLD ABOUT
IT AT THE TIME?
WHAT DID HE SAY TO VLADIMIR
PUTIN?
HE TOLD HIM TO CUT IT OUT.
I BET PUTIN WAS QUAKING IN HIS
BOOTS AFTER THAT.
ESPECIALLY AFTER OBAMA TOLD THE
WHOLE WORLD THAT DICTATORS COULD
GET AWAY WITH ANYTHING ON HIS
WATCH AFTER HE LET SYRIA THOUGHT
HIS REDLINE AND CHEMICAL
WEAPONS.
BY CONTRAST, IT IS TRUMP WHO PUT
TOUGH SANCTIONS ON RUSSIA THAT
EXPELLED DIPLOMATS WHO ON THE
UKRAINIANS AND ABOVE ALL,
TOTALLY CHANGED AMERICA'S ENERGY
POLICY AND WAY RUSSIA HATES.
WHO WAS IT WHO LAUNCHED AN
ACTUAL CYBER ATTACK ON RUSSIA
WITH ACTUAL MEDDLING?
NOT OBAMA BUT DONALD TRUMP.
I THINK THAT IS TOUGHER THAN CUT
IT OUT, VLADIMIR.
LET'S GET REAL.
THIS IS ABOUT SUBSTANCE FOR
NATIONAL SECURITY OR EVEN
ELECTION MEDDLING BUT IT IS YOUR
POLITICS AND MEMBER THAT
TOMORROW.
WE ARE HOURS AWAY FROM THE
DEADLINE DURING OTHER HAS SET
FOR THE RELEASE OF CONGRESS OF
THE UNREDACTED LITERARY REPORT.
>> ATTORNEY GENERAL WE HAVE TO
GOT A LETTER LATE LAST NIGHT
REFUSING TO ADHERE TO THE
SUBPOENA AND THIS IS
INDEFENSIBLE AND PART OF THE
ATTACK ON AMERICAN DEMOCRACY BY
THIS ADMINISTRATION.
STEVE: HE WANTS THE UNREDACTED
REPORT MUST HAVE THE UNREDACTED
REPORT THAT DEMOCRACY DEPENDS ON
IT.
BUT HE ALREADY HAS GOT IT.
ADLER, YOU TOTAL CHARLATAN
THERE'S A REPORT AVAILABLE TO
YOU WITHOUT THREE OF THE FOUR
REDUCTIONS IN THE PUBLIC VERSION
THAT YOU DID NOT EVEN BOTHER TO
GO LOOK AT IT.
LAST WEEK YOU HAD TO WALK DOWN
THE STREET AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HEADQUARTERS.
IT TAKES 20 MINUTES ACCORDING TO
GOOGLE MAPS.
THIS WEEK IT MOVED RIGHT TO
CAPITOL HILL AND IT IS LITERALLY
IN YOUR BUILDING.
MUELLER REPORT WITHOUT THREE OF
THE FOUR TYPES OF REACTIONS
REMOVING IS LITERALLY ON THE
LAW.
YOU ARE THE ONE GOING ON BUT ANY
DEMOCRACY IN THIS BUS IS ALL
BECAUSE THE MUELLER REPORT DID
NOT GIVE THE ESTABLISHMENT WHAT
THEY WANTED AND NOW THEY ARE
TAKING THE RUSSIAN NONSENSE
GOING BY SAYING THE WHOLE THING
IS A COVER-UP BY AN ATTORNEY
GENERAL WHO IS SOMEWHAT UNHINGED
NANCY PELOSI CALLED A LIAR BACK
HE LIED TO CONGRESS AND REBELS
TO THAT IT WOULD BE CONSIDERED A
CRIME.
NOBODY IS ABOVE THE LAW, NOT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND NOT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
STEVE: THIS IS THE MOMENT HE
SUPPOSEDLY LIGHT.
>> REPORTS HAVE EMERGED RECENTL
RECENTLY, GENERAL, THE MEMBERS
OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S TEAM
ARE FRUSTRATED AT SOME LEVEL
WITH LIMITED INFORMATION
INCLUDED IN YOUR MARCH 24 LETTER
THAT IT DOES NOT ADEQUATELY OR
ACCURATELY NECESSARILY PORTRAYED
THE REPORT'S FINDINGS AND YOU
KNOW WHAT THEY ARE REFERENCING
WITH THAT?
BACK NO I DO NOT.
>> WHEN YOU CUT IT RIGHT THERE
IT DOES SOUND LIKE HE LIED BUT
WHEN HE SAID THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAD ROBERT MUELLER'S
LETTER ASKING FOR HIS SUMMARY TO
BE PUT OUT.
BUT THAT WAS NOT THE FULL
ANSWER.
HERE IS THE REST.
>> I SUSPECT THAT THEY PROBABLY
WANTED MORE PUT OUT BUT IN MY
VIEW, I WAS NOT INTERESTED IN
PUTTING OUT SUMMARIES OR TRYING
TO SUMMARIZE.
STEVE: HE LITERALLY DESCRIBED
THE SUBSTANCE OF MUELLER'S
COMPLAINTS.
IT WAS NOT BARR WHO LIED BUT
NANCY.
AS USUAL, THEY ARE PROJECTING
AND ACCUSING OTHERS OF THE VERY
THING THEY DO ALL THE TIME.
JUST LOOK AT THIS.
>> DO YOU KNOW IF THE BUREAU OF
RELIED ON THE STEEL DOSSIER AS
ANY COURT FILINGS?
APPLICATIONS, PETITIONS,
PLEADINGS --
>> I HAVE NO --
>> TO THE CIA RELY ON THIS?
>> NO.
>> WHY NOT?
BECAUSE IT WAS NOT PART OF THE
OFFICE OF INTELLIGENCE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAD AND IT
WAS NOT IN ANY WAY USED AS A
BASIS FOR THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY ASSESSMENT THAT WAS
DONE.
STEVE: WHY IS NOT NANCY CALLING
FOR BRENNAN TO BE PROSECUTED FOR
LYING TO CONGRESS?
BECAUSE THEY ARE ALL ON THE SAME
TEAM.
THE ESTABLISHMENT HE TRIED TO
KEEP THE FOCUS ON RUSSIA.
ANOTHER TACTIC IS PRETENDING
THIS WAS NEVER ABOUT COLLUSION
AND THE MOST LAUGHABLE EXAMPLE
CAME DURING THE COVERAGE OF LAST
WEEK'S BAR HEARING WHEN NBC'S
BRIAN WILLIAMS CUT IN WITH THIS
IMPORTANT ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> A PHRASE OR LACK OF IT IS
ABSENCE FROM FEDERAL CODE, THIS
NO COLLUSION MANTRA, IS SO
CONDITIONAL TO WHY WE ARE HERE
TODAY THAT WE DECIDED TO FLAG IT
WHEN WE HEARD HIM USE IT YET
AGAIN.
STEVE: BRAVE COLLUSION, NOT A
THING, NOT AT ALL AND THOUGHT
ABOUT COLLUSION -- BRIAN?
>> COLLUSION, COLLUSION,
COLLUSION, COLLUSION.
>> FOR THE RECORD THE PRESIDENT
HAS SAID COLLUSION 94 TIMES ON
TWITTER.
STEVE: NEARLY AS MUCH AS YOU BUT
THE MOST STRANGE CLAIM FROM THE
ESTABLISHMENT IS THAT WILLIAM
BARR IS RUNNING A COVER-UP.
>> THIS IS ROBERT MUELLER SAYING
HEY, ATTORNEY GENERAL BAR, STOP
LYING ABOUT MY REPORT.
IT GIVES US A TON OF NEW
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW HARD
MUELLER HAS BEEN FIGHTING TO TRY
TO GET HIS REPORT OUT AND HOW
MANY TIMES AND HOW MANY WAYS
BARR HAS BEEN BLOCKING THAT FROM
HAPPENING.
FAR COVERED UP MUELLER'S
FINDINGS IN THIS IS REPRESENTING
THE FINDINGS AND REFUSING TO
RELEASE THE FINDINGS EXPOSING
MUELLER'S PERSONAL FIGHT AGAINST
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION TO TRY
TO UNDO THE COVER-UP OF HIS
INVESTIGATION AND FIND IT.
STEVE: OKAY.
PUBLISHING SOMETHING IS NOW
COVERING IT UP.
I THINK WE NEED TO DEMAND MSNBC
STOP COVERING UP RACHEL MADDOX
MONOLOGUES.
AMERICA NEEDS TO HEAR WHAT SHE
HAS TO SAY.
EVERY WEEKNIGHT AT 9:00 P.M.
DEMOCRACY DEPENDS ON IT.
THERE IS RACHEL TRYING TO GET
HER OPINION OUT ON HOW MANY
TIMES AND IN MANY WAYS THAT
[INAUDIBLE] HAS BEEN BLOCKING
THAT AND COVERED UP RACHEL
MADDOW'S MONOLOGUE.
MAYBE HE'S WORKING FOR SEAN
HANNITY OR THE RUSSIANS?
STEVE: EVEN ON ITS OWN CRAZY
LOGIC THE COVER-UP THEORY MAKES
NO SENSE ACCORDING TO THE RANGED
ESTABLISHMENT AND THE GOVERNMENT
WAS REVEALED BY THE COMPLAINT
LETTER AND A BIT THEY POINT TO
IS THIS.
SUMMARY LETTER THE DEPARTMENT
SENT TO CONGRESS AND RELEASED IN
THE PUBLIC LATE IN THE AFTERNOON
MARCH 24 NOT FULLY CAPTURE THE
CONTACT, NATURE AND SUBSTANCE OF
THIS OFFICE'S WORK AND
CONCLUSIONS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE SUBSTANCE.
THE AIM OF MUELLER WAS TO
INVESTIGATE RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE
AND ANY COORDINATION BY THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN PLUS OBSTRUCTION.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT BARR
ADDRESSED IN HIS ORIGINAL
LETTER.
NO INDICTMENT ON ANY OF IT.
THAT IS THE SUBSTANCE AND IT
JUST THAT THE ESTABLISHMENT DOES
NOT LIKE IT IN MUELLER'S LETTER
COMPLAINED ABOUT PUBLIC
CONFUSION AND MISUNDERSTANDING
AND YOU CAN SEE WHY THE PUBLIC
WOULD CONFUSE FOR YEARS THEY
BEEN TOLD TRUMP WAS A RUSSIAN
AGENT BUT MUELLER SAID HE
WASN'T.
AFTER THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
ANNOUNCED THAT FACT MUELLER
WANTED TO PUT MORE OUT THERE.
THAT WHEN I HAVE CHANGED THE
SUBSTANCE BUT WOULD HAVE CHANGED
THE SPIN.
NOW, WHY THE HELL DOES MUELLER
CARE ABOUT ANY OF THAT?
FROM PUBLIC UNDERSTANDING, MEDIA
COVERAGE, SPEND, THE
ESTABLISHMENT LOVES DISCOVERING
ATTORNEY GENERAL BAR IS' LAWYER
BUT BY HIS OWN LETTER, ROBERT
MUELLER TOLD US HOW HE SEES
HIMSELF.
HE IS THE ESTABLISHMENT SPIN
DOCTOR.
MANY IN THE MEDIA SAY HOW CAN
YOU QUESTION MUELLER HE'S A
REPUBLICAN BUT THIS IS THE WHOLE
POINT.
THE BIG RIGHT HERE IS NOT
BETWEEN REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS BUT BETWEEN THE
ASTONISHMENT AND POPULISM
BETWEEN INSIDERS AND OUTSIDERS.
MUELLER IS THE ULTIMATE INSIDER.
AS WE TOLD YOU IN A SWAMP WATCH
A FEW MONTHS AGO.
ROBERT MUELLER SLOPPINESS GOES
BEYOND AWARDING BILLION-DOLLAR
CONTRACTS TO HIS BEST FRIEND'S
EMPLOYER.
AFTER LEAVING HIS POST AS FBI
DIRECTOR WHAT DID THIS MODERN
DAY SAINT AND THIS PARAGON OF
ETHICS AND INTEGRITY DO?
HE CASHED IN.
MUELLER WENT BACK TO WORK WITH
HIS OLD LAW AND LOBBYING FIRM
NOW CALLED WILMER HALE IN
SURPRISE, SURPRISE IT WAS
ELECTED TO GOVERNMENT WORK.
ONE OF THEM WAS A LIKE LUCK
[INAUDIBLE] BLOOMBERG HAS CALLED
HIM THE WORLD'S MOST PROFITABLE
BY AGENCY.
STEVE: THIS WHOLE RUSSIA MANIA
IS ABOUT THE ESTABLISHMENTS
FIGHTING BACK AND HAS NO BETTER
EXAMPLE THAN THAT THEN NICOLE
WALLACE.
>> ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO TURNS
OUT TO BE DONALD TRUMP WITH A
BRAIN WHAT YOU MAKE OF THE
COMPLETE DEPARTURE FROM REALITY
BETWEEN THE REPUBLICANS HAVE
GONE TO A LAND ONLY FAMILIAR TO
DIEHARD VIEWERS OF FOX NEWS
PRIMETIME?
YES, TRUMP SHOULD GET THE BLAME
BUT IT WOULD SEEM THAT WHEN THE
PEOPLE AROUND HIM BECOME
POLLUTED BY HIS LACK OF ANY SORT
OF CHARACTER THAT THERE IS
REASON TO WORRY ABOUT THOSE
PEOPLE.
WILLIAM BARR IS SAYING -- LIKE
WATCHING THE PRINCESS BRIDE.
UP IS DOWN, DOWN IS UP AND THE
FLOOR IS THE FEELING AND FEELING
AS A FLOOR SO WHAT WAS THAT
TODAY?
>> GOOD QUESTION.
NICOLE WALLACE AND THE REST OF
HER ESTABLISHMENT SHOULD ASK IT
OF THEMSELVES.
THEY LIE ABOUT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL BEING A LIAR AND ACCUSE
TRUMP HAVE BEEN PUTIN'S PUPPET
WHEN THEY ARE THE ONES HELPING
PUTIN DIVIDE AMERICA.
THEY CONDEMN TALK OF DEEP STATES
BUYING AS A SMEAR EVEN THOUGH
THERE'S PLENTY OF EVIDENCE FOR
IT ALL THEY SPENT THE LAST TWO
YEARS SMEARING THE PRESIDENT AS
A RUSSIAN AGENT WITH NO EVIDENCE
AT ALL.
THEY ARE THE ONES, THESE
ESTABLISHMENT SYCOPHANTS WHO
SCREAM ABOUT TRUMP UNDERMINING
DEMOCRACY IN THE ROOM OF OFF
WHEN IT'S ALL THEM.
IT IS YOU, CHUCK WALLACE AND YOU
DURING OTHER AND YOU, ADAM
SCHIFF.
AND YOU REFUSING TO ACCEPT AN
ELECTION AND USING EVERY TRICK
IN THE BOOK TO OVERTURN ITS
RESULTS.